avec nous maintenant j'en boive un
directeur général de Black Rock en Seine
sous gouverneur de la Banque du Canada
est sous ministre délégué aux finances à
Ottawa en bois vert
alors quand vous regardez ça vous au
micro taux d'intérêt inflation ce
cocktail on comprend quoi comment vous
allez et la situation
la barre il faut il faut garder le cas
dans la station et puis la même chose
qui était pour nous
depuis
c'est comme si on pouvait s'imaginer que
le micro on peut ralentir l'économie à
très court terme mais c'est de la
croissance déplacé plus tard en 2022 et
donc c'est toi qui la nature
année 2021
[Musique]
combinaison de la
première fois
qu'on a pas vu il faut
prier
donc ce que je viens de caractériser
comme scénarios de base
centrale
mais d'une façon qu'elle aurait eu
des bonnes raisons pour toi
cette semaine
[Musique]
plus les marchés qu'est-ce qu'on a vu
jusqu'à maintenant et qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire aussi pour les tais-toi
technologique qui sont très sensibles et
on voit une démarcation souvent attaqué
le reste du marché les apporter ce la
maison
qu'on a vu en 2021 à plusieurs reprises
c'est un espèce de
des changements de communication de la
part de
négatif pour le
[Musique]
retour de ce soir
je vous souhaite de joyeuses fêtes merci
à vous merci